This is gonna work Steve...
....I know it is...
cuz I don't know what I'm gonna do if it doesn't
" hi ah...is anyone home???"
"This is scott lang....
we met a few years ago...
at the airport...?
in germany??
I got really big..
Is this an old message?
Ant-Man...-Ant-Man- I  know you know..- I know you know that...
That's the front door!!..
That's me..can you buzz me in??
Alright..
control's online...
The collection unit activates when you decouple it..
It should automatically start absorbing Quantum Heeling particles.
Also…..make sure you stay out of the Tardigrade fields…
They're cute…..but, they will eat you…
And don’t get sucked into a Time Vortex…..
We won’t be able to save you….
…*hmm*…
Okay….
Going subatomic in 5…
..4..
..3..
..2..
..1.
Hey everybody, it's Charlie.
So we got to talk about that Avengers 4 endgame trailer...
...And the ant-man scene
Everybody has started to notice now..
that there is archival footage
So we need to talk about how ant-man is suddenly
The Most important character in the MCU
and how his dirty old beat-up Funny-looking van..
is suddenly one of the most important pieces of technology in the universe
There's a new round of that IMAX ticket giveaway too -
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
And leave your favorite moment from the trailer on the video...
charting the timeline in this clip
You have Captain America and the other surviving Avengers sitting in the Avengers facility
Talking about what they've lost trying to figure out what to do next
So he shaved his beard
So a little bit of time has gone by,
but not that much time
because black widow's hair is still blonde and very short
So using their relative beard level and hair level
It seems like they didn't spend too much time in Wakanda after the 'snapening'.
They went back to the New Avengers facility
They're regrouping and looking through archival footage
Like you have the scene of Bruce Banner looking at all the people they've lost
I know there are a lot of people wondering about Shuri here
If it's one of the..
'false trailer moments'
like they're doing a bit of a fake out to mislead you...
because a while ago the Russos did say that Shuri was one of
The people that survived the snap
So because, we know that they told a bold-faced lie a little while ago,
also talking about the 'Endgame, title
"Oh, that's totally not the title**wink wink**"
which of course it actually is now.
I've seen some conspiracy theories about that, too
Maybe the title is a fake out!!
unless I see some more compelling evidence, I do think that 'Endgame' is the real title
But yes,...
...there are probably a couple false moments in this trailer
Shuri is probably one of them.
But as they're looking through all this footage
Somehow this clip gets queued from the front gate
Maybe the system recognizes Scott Lang is one of the Avengers
You don't really know how Tony Starks database works..
Because even though,....
....he might be stuck in outer space, all of his technology is still operating..
..like it normally should.
There's not a whole lot else in this frame that tells you when this is happening ..
when ant-man pulls up
because you see the 1983 date,
it just says: "strat :1983 : archive" in the upper left hand corner
But you look at the front gate and it looks kind of overgrown like it's unkempt..
people haven't been visiting it that often
There's a big sign on the front of the gate.....
and we actually do have a couple shots of the Avengers base in the trailer
And we saw them drive through the front gate
during spider-man homecoming and it looks way nicer
So this obviously seems like it's happening during a different time period
probably during 1983....
But that's where you get to that ant-man post-credit scene
Janet Van Dyne just reminding him
"Don't fall into a Time Vortices....
....we won't be able to save you".
She makes it sound like they're very unpredictable
so a lot of people are just taking this to be
confirmation that they're paying off that 'Time Vortices'....
....comment and he accidentally time travels....
....and jumps around till he finally winds up in this scene here
But even though it might be confirmation of-
Ant-Man Time-traveling-
using 'Quantum Energy' and the 'Quantum Realm',-
he's not a genius.
So this is something that he'd have to be doing on accident
He'd had to fall into one of the time vortices.,...
and then find someone
who is smart enough
to understand how his quantum gear works
and then enable him to go back in time
because him falling into a time vortice to see
Doesn't explain how the van
Travels in time with him-
because this is definitely his van it probably has that 'Quantum Tunnel, in the back of it
but that's not exactly how time travel works-
like if he fell into a 'Time Vortices' inside the Quantum realm-
then how would the van outside of the quantum realm also travel back with him?
That would just be really weird
so, the most logical way to explain this,
-like adding another layer of crazy-
is that him in this clip here is NOT the first time-
that he's traveled through time using the Quantum realm!!....
what would have to happen is.....
....is that he escapes the quantum realm at the beginning of Avengers 4,
-and accidentally winds up in the future
So that the van is still there when he gets out of the Quantum realm,-
he finds everything is very different
But he's able to track down an older version of Cassie Lang (his daughter)-
-and other Avengers 'science bros'-
who were smart enough to help him figure out what's going on??-
-catch him up to speed on what Thanos did-
-and help reconfigure his technology-
because it's further in the future, so maybe they'll have more advanced science
That's more capable of fine-tuning the 'Quantum Energy Gear'
So he goes back in time to try and warn the Avengers-
-but. because it's still imprecise,....
he accidentally overshoots the mark and winds up back in 1983.
So that would mean that he'd also have to time-travel again to get back to present-day
Probably with the help of other Avengers along the way.
There were rumors that John Slattery's Howard Stark was spotted on the set of Avengers 4 .
In 1983, Howard Stark was still very much alive
So he could go seek him out thinking that he was trying to find somebody related to Iron Man.
You're smart
You can help me figure this stuff out....
(early theory)
Maybe that has something to do with it
because he's just not smart enough to figure this stuff out all by himself
He's not a scientist.
He's a thief.
But if you were wondering there are smart people in the MCU that are alive in 1983
So there are people that could help him-
like Nick Fury would still be alive
What does that mean for the actual plot of Avengers 4 though?
Like I said,-
Ant-Man's van if he can travel through time with him,-
is suddenly the most important piece of technology In the entire universe
because the only other way to do that is to use the time stone and Thanos still has the charred Infinity Gauntlet-
in what seems like a couple years after the events of the snap.
so like he's on his farm the gauntlet is still broken,
but he's still got it here. I know he's walking through the field with it on
He probably takes it off at some point
but there been a lot of rumors about
Footage that they're cutting in how like Thanos will realize what they're doing if they're traveling through time
Messing with things.
If he starts seeing gems
Disappear at random from the gauntlet-
like if he were standing in his field here on titan to just enjoying life
Happy with himself and all of a sudden he noticed one of the infinity gems just winked out of existence
He would probably instantly realize what the Avengers are doing
"They're using time-travel to try and alter what I did"
So early timeline of the movie -
' you see Tony Stark running out of power in the guardians ship-
with nebula' -
because remember they were stuck on Titan....
....but the guardianship was there.
So he's obviously using it to try and get back home.
This is where they're coming from
This is where planet Earth is
like I said
Captain Marvel is probably in Kree and Skrull space-
in the 20-year period that she's missing so she's probably the closest person
Nearby that can help pick them up on the way home
or rescue them if she gets a distress signal -
even the people at NASA
Are trying to get in on the fun!!....
The NASA Twitter account was talking about pointing all of our Communications energy
towards deep space to try and pick up his distress signal
We've never really dealt with energy reserves issues in the Marvel Universe
Typically when ships travel from one point to another in outer space
They travel through a wormhole and it seems like a jump cut series like a really short funny scene
That just looks really cool. And it seems like it happens almost instantaneously
The only reason why Iron Man and nebula would be stuck in outer space-
is if the parts that help them travel through those wormholes
Were broken and they didn't have anything to fix them with -
even iron man's technology
His nanobots weren't enough to fix that.
Because he says that he's run out of food
I'm guessing that this is a matter of weeks
Maybe not quite months after the end of the snap
Captain America with no beard, Black Widow with the really short hair, -
....also a matter of months after the snap.
Them standing here on the back where they're talking about whether or not the plan is actually going to work, -
....she still has really short hair
So this is probably relatively soon after they find out what's going on with Ant-Man.
Thor sitting here
Just sulking to himself....
....also probably pretty early in the movie.
If you're just talking about when these scenes happen during the actual movie,
I think that most of this footage from the trailer is from the first 20 minutes.
Like we've seen footage from behind the scenes with-
....Black Widow with really long red and blonde hair.
So like her roots are just growing back out because she has naturally red hair.
But that would take a while to happen
So you just have to assume that all the footage we see of her and probably most of these other people happen-
relatively early in the film-
before any really big time jumps or before they jump around in time a whole bunch.
The other thing you have to remember too is this is all part of....
Dr Strange's one chance in 14 million that he saw that them winning-
....and the Russos did address that people asked him straight up-
"How come Doctor Strange didn't mention anything about what they should do-
or what might happen??"
But the real reason is probably because telling someone how to do things-
and what their future is going to be usually winds up-
....leading to some different outcome that Doctor Strange would not want.
So everybody post your time-travel theories in the comments below
What do you think? The timeline is for ant-man during the movie?
what'll happen is is they'll be more Marvel stuff happening next week
They still have to drop that Spider-Man Far From Home trailer-
and there's going to be more trailers from other people-
coming before the end of the year.
leave your requests in the comments below
Congratulations 'OscarDoesStuff'....
you're the giveaway winner for my last big Marvel video.
Please email me on the about page of my channel
So I can get your contact details
Click here to re-watch the Avengers Endgame trailer a billion more times.
And click here for my breakdown of the Spider-Man Far From Home trailer-
in a big Comic Con panel that they just did.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everybody stay Awesome.
See you guys tonight